[Music]
meet you where you been I could show you
incredible things Taylor Swift has been
keeping a low profile in recent months
and now et knows why I'm dying to see
how this one a source tells ET the shake
it off singer is busy working on her
upcoming album and it could be out by
years in as far as the musical direction
goes I would always like to keep people
on their toes back in September pal Gigi
Hadid dished on why it was special to
have Swift step out for her Tommy he'll
take your runway show she's obviously
such a great friend and you know she is
starting to go back to work into the
studio again and really made time to be
here for me so I'm so grateful for that
it's been two months since Taylor's last
public performance at a pre-super bowl
event and more than a month since going
on her social media silence an
eyewitness tells us Swift has been
staying close to home and was spotted
driving around Nashville last week quote
she comes here to get away from the
paparazzi
[Music]